mistral a dit l'argile est aux mains du
santonnier ce qu'est l'homme dans les
mains de dieu en provence c'est au
xviiie siècle qu'apparaissent les
premiers santons et les crèches les plus
humbles avec des personnages autour de
la sainte famille et ce petit peuple
tout simple parfumez du thym des
collines résiste à la tourmente
révolutionnaire de 1789 il quitte les
églises fermées et se réfugie chez le
fit du riste chacun veut avoir chez soi
sa propre crèche et jean-louis laniel le
premier santonniers exposera ses oeuvres
des 1803 à la première foire aux santons
à marseille avant de rencontrer les
santonniers d'aujourd'hui
rendons hommage au musée du vieux
marseille qui a réuni des santons datant
de 1830 à 1935 rouge vif ou au creux de
ré la belle terre de la provence qui
recouvre compte des vallons témoigne de
la présence de formations argileuse
mais si le santonnier s'est établi dans
ce merveilleux pays
c'est aussi que l'air y est plus pur que
partout ailleurs comme disait marcel
pagnol et l'art y naît spontanément au
bout des doigts qui façonnent ce petit
membre d'argile dans la carrière des
mille voix si paul phuc san antonio
depuis 1934
meilleur ouvrier de france
je vais chercher ma terre parce que pour
nous c'est très important d'avoir
unitaire très pur nous cherchons dans
les veines il ya des terres qui seront
un peu sableuses et qui nous font pas
pour mourir nous faut lutter très très
grâce aux propos à faire des sujets
traités
ce peut-être que j'ai choisi dans la
carrière transporter chez moi je la mets
attentes et cela dès les jeux la tamise
très liquides et je leur monnaie les
bassins de décantation pendant la
période d'été seulement parce que le
soleil ne terminent leur apport à sion
le surplus d'eau et qu'elle j'ai atteint
une pâte qui ne colle plus au doigt je
la dessine karl pour la conserver pour
l'hiver et même pour plusieurs années
oh
tout cet été a qui étaient conservés en
cave de la saur la création des
personnages
donc je prends un bloc de terre je
modèle un personnage à la main des
personnages qui sommes toujours
traditionnels
à
je choisis les personnels de traditions
provençales les pastorales nous servent
énormément
et puis la vie il faut être observateur
pour retrouver les personnages comme moi
dans la vie courante tout en les
habillant navette ou de l'époque
ancienne puisque le salto est d'environ
dix huitième siècle
je n'ai jamais suivi de cours de 17 mai
tout en temps j'ai toujours été
passionné par la crèche et le jour où
j'ai pu de mes mains de faire quelque
chose avec mes doigts j'ai essayé de
faire des saltos et depuis 1934 je
m'amuse le modèle
je crée des santons traditionnels tu te
fasses en les chantant à environ du
xviiie siècle se recueillent toujours
nous travaillons toujours de la même
manière
et voilà le sens en étant terminée je
vais en établir un moule pour pouvoir
les faire de série je couche mon
personnage de la terre pour en faire un
contrôle je me servir à ce que le plâtre
ne passait pas par dessous que ça ne
passe pas d'aspérités
je vais faire un coffrage une fois le
mot comme trop mou le terminer je vais
couler une première partie de plâtre
voilà terminé
ces personnages que je crée sont soit
des pièces uniques pour des personnes
qui me les communes directement soit des
personnages je fais un modèle ou
j'établis un moule pour pouvoir le
rendre commercial c'est-à-dire pour
pouvoir faire de la série c'est le seul
moyen
de pouvoir produire et de pouvoir les
vendre dans un prix assez raisonnable
le moulage des temps terminé il s'agit
de laisser sécher les 100 tonnes très
lentement le temps de séchage est très
variable selon l'importance de la pièce
cela peut varier entre les jours et deux
mois pendant la période de séchage le
100 ans diminue de dimension c'est à
dire qu'il perd à peu près 7 ou 8% de sa
grandeur et or voici une scène temps qui
viennent sortir du moule
voyez le même symptôme qui a séché et
qui a perdu à peu près deux ou trois
centimètres à l'origine les symptômes
province n'était pas cuit il était
uniquement terres asséchées et décoré à
la peinture à l'eau mais le jour le 5
ans et vendu hors de la province
il a fallu l'espé dié il a donc fallu le
durcir on cuit actuellement au four
électrique parce que c'est beaucoup plus
pratique mais j'ai pu moi-même pendant
dix ans au four à bois toute façon c'est
qu'il faut c'est atteindre les 900
degrés pour que le symptôme craignent
plus l'humidité
il nous faut environ 13 heures de feu et
48 heures de refroidissement avant de
sortir les personnages
les symptômes sont plus maintenant
tous ces symptômes qui était bien rangé
dans un fourré en les sortant
ils ont chargé de couloir irg la terre
qui était un peu jaune au départ est
venue rouge vraie terre cuite
maintenant reste à passer à la
décoration la décoration se paie
généralement un série c'est-à-dire pour
gagner du temps et toutes les vestes
tous les pantalons tout les bleus enfin
par couleur on peut décorer soit à
l'huile soit à la gouache
mais le sortant de province en principe
et mat
ce travail en famille que j'ai des
compagnons qui ont été apprenti chez moi
qui continue maintenant ouvriers
malheureusement la nouvelle législation
ne nous permet plus de faire des
appentis notre métier n'ayant pas
d'école et n'ayant pas de ces ap
nous n'avons plus ce privilège de
pouvoir apprendre des jeunes et c'est
bien dommage tous ces personnages vont
servir à faire des crèches provençales
rien n'est défini exactement le nombre
de personnages leur taille
chacun compose la crèche à sa façon et
tel qu'il boit la province
j'ai créé un personnage que j'ai
intitulé coup de mistral après avoir vu
justement une personne en difficulté
dans la terre
e
cette espèce est une pièce unique qui a
été entièrement l'année pour le concours
de meilleur ouvrier de france
plus de mille heures de travail
je l' ai commencé d'ailleurs un peu le
temps perdu et puis je les termine est
vraiment attendre trouver parce que le
concours arriver il fallait que la pièce
sur pattes dans le centre de la ville et
zenonia pouvons les ateliers d'un autre
créateur marcel carbonel riz est lui
aussi meilleur ouvrier ambitieux oui
justement je voulais vous téléphonez
votre commande doit partir aujourd'hui
c'est bien pour l' agence de washington
une activité régionale et internationale
nous avons environ 40 % de notre
production qui est prise par
exploitation
nos sujets sont énormément prisé parce
que le travail de thierry cuite et
quelque chose un peu exceptionnel dans
le monde
le cerf-volant de la gouache
ce sont des pigments que nous fabriquons
nous-mêmes qui une fois broyés nous
devons à ces couleurs là et ses couleurs
après sont destinés à être mélangés sur
le marbre la diverses couverts chaque
atelier fait sa cuisine
et comme les cuisiniers etc à s'accuser
deuxième essai d'après certains mélanges
qu'on arrive à retenir des plus
délicate comme les plus violentes nous
travaillons d'après construit en 1850
1860 et tous les modèles ont été
entièrement créé par mois là vous voyez
un modèle destiné à la croix rouge qui
doit émettre un timbre en fin d'année et
vous voyez les maquettes là ce sont des
photos de vieux centre qui ont 150 à 160
ans d'âge et qui ont été réinterprétés à
ma façon à saint-victoret près de
l'aéroport de marseille-marignane
maurice paul un authentique provençal
créé depuis peu des santons habillés
j'ai filmé plusieurs métiers y conclut
chauffeur est acquis à paris diverses
péripéties mois monnaie a offert ensuite
les pâtes fraîches
l'un provence et l'a peut-être par
hérédité
en effet mon grand père était dans
l'argile il ya presque certains l'amour
du pays de larges ils auront fait que je
sais c est que je réussisse un peu à me
reconvertir dans les sens donc ma femme
et moi nous formons une équipe nous
avons partagé notre travail ma femme
s'occupe du tissu de la coupure de la
finition des symptômes et de la poste et
des accessoires
dans le montage descente en habit il ya
plusieurs techniques
nous avons choisi la technique où le
corps est solidaire de la tête ce qui
forme un seul morceau d'argile
les pieds sont en argile héros liées à
ce corps par des fils de fer de même que
les mains ça permet de donner une allure
plus vivante et plus vrai
et
non
e
une
c'est une création perpétuelle jamais
deux sans toi sont exactement les mêmes
qu'elle tourne ou les terminaux que le
monde sur son socle
koné ajoute tous les accessoires on se
rend compte que par les mouvements des
bras ou des jambes
l'attitude du centre échanges et ce qui
fait que ces santons ont chacun leur vie
propre pour ainsi dire
m
il tend notre petit monde d'argile en
compagnie des vielles des tambourins
salle thériault et flutey des musiciens
de provence qui accompagne la farandole
de noces en cours
et
je sais